mortal kombat legends battle of the
realms follows the franchise's animated
debut mortal kombat legend scorpion's
revenge which introduced viewers to an
animated take on the mortal kombat
universe here's the ending of mortal
kombat legends battle of the realms
explained to begin discussing battle of
the realms it's important to understand
where scorpion's revenge left off in the
world of mortal kombat legends as usual
in most retellings of the famous
original mortal kombat tournament lord
raiden protector of earth realm and god
of thunder brings together earth's
champions to compete in the mortal
kombat tournament designed by the elder
gods to allow the realms a chance to
fight for power over one another in
earth realms case it's a chance to
protect earth from an incursion by the
forces of outworld in the final moments
of the tournament scorpion intervenes
and beheads goro just before the monster
can deliver a finishing blow to liu kang
scorpion also manages to trick shang
tsung and obtains a special key to free
the mad elder guard shinnok thanks to
scorpion's interference earth realm wins
the tournament and liu kang is crowned
the winner as a result scorpion kills
sub-zero believing him to be the culprit
behind the orchestrated deaths of his
family and clan but it's revealed that
the never realm sorcerer quan chi
actually committed this heinous crime
scorpion finally obtains his revenge as
he brutalizes the sorcerer before
finishing him off in the aftermath of
that fight scorpion resigns himself to
another death as the island crumbles
around him
after a short prologue the battle of the
realms quite literally begins with the
battle between realms some time after
the tournament outworld plans and enacts
an invasion of earthrealm katana who is
still under the thumb of shao khan is
leading the forces of outworld in an
all-out offensive special forces figures
like sonia blade jack spriggs and curtis
stryker take up defensive positions
against the incursion with the help of
kung lao and lord raiden apparently
earth realm's victory in the mortal
kombat tournament is being ignored by
shao khan during the battle shao khan
enters the battlefield but not to fight
he offers raiden a chance to resolve the
conflict through one final tournament
and raiden agrees seizing the
opportunity to save future generations
from the responsibility of defending
earth realm by ending it all here and
now shao khan and lord raiden petition
the elder gods to make the tournaments
happen shockingly rayden also sacrifices
his godhood in order to participate in
the tournament alongside his heroes
while the rest of the characters are
waging war against one another scorpion
finds himself back in netherrealm
following his fated battle with the
villainous quan chi however instead of
quan chi this time it's shinnok a
corrupt elder god who greets him waiting
patiently shinnok seeks to use the key
scorpion obtained from shang tsung to
unlock an ancient power the problem is
that the ki has now fused itself with
scorpion's soul so shinnok threatens
scorpion with eternal pain and torment
should he not use the power of the key
on the temple of elements but scorpion
doesn't take kindly to threats and he
quickly ditches the elder guard and his
minions elsewhere kuai yang and smoke
members of the linguay train before
being commanded by their grandmaster to
bring scorpion in alive liang is
reluctant to accept the mantle of
sub-zero but he is emboldened by the
thought of killing scorpion who murdered
his brother bihan ultimately the
grandmaster betrays his own clan by
damning them to a life of programmed
servitude as cyborgs and cyrax and
sector appear as newly constructed
cybernetic warriors the grandmaster
wishes the same for sub-zero and smoke
and in their struggle to escape cyrax
and sector smoke is taken by the cyborgs
and eventually converted into one
himself
as promised by outworld's ruler shao
khan as well as lord raiden a tournament
commences that tests the metal of each
realm's champions true to the video game
franchise the fights pack a
bone-crunching punch followed by
countless buckets of blood and gore some
combatants lose but are lucky enough to
be spared a grisly death like johnny
cage and jax others aren't so fortunate
quickly curtis stryker and kung lao are
eviscerated by prominent outworld
combatants shang tsung and xiao khan the
combat is bloody vicious and thrilling
for fans of the franchise at a pivotal
moment katana is ordered by xiao khan to
fight raiden and while both are
competent fighters katana gains the
upper hand ready to unleash a killing
blow katana strikes seemingly hitting
her true target xiao khan with her blade
seeking freedom from his tyranny for
herself and the realms she defects and
joins those opposing outworld shao khan
however isn't finished he vows to make
katana watch as he destroys the realms
the tournament continues with liu kang
and shang tsung the sorcerer disables
one of liu kang's arms with a curse but
the shaolin warrior manages to defeat
shang soon regardless
despite being manipulated by his
grandmaster and losing smoke to the
cyborg program kuwai liang still
harbours deep-seated anger towards
scorpion for the murder of his brother
bihan interestingly scorpion regrets
killing bihan and has learned that
vengeance is an empty pursuit
despite their differences the duo
determines that they must join forces
against the lin kuei cyborgs to stop
them from using the key to unleashing
disaster upon all the realms their
attempt to stop the impending doom is
foiled however when the two are
overwhelmed by the cyborgs scorpion is
taken to the temple of elements and
forced to place his hands upon the door
to open the ancient vault inside the
temple lies a kami dogu one piece of
many that when collected summoned the
power of the one being the linque
grandmaster delivers his piece of the
kamidogu to shinnok who is revealed to
be the clan's client
in the lore of the mortal kombat video
games particularly mortal kombat
deception the one being is considered
the progenitor of the realms on the
mortal kombat storyline before life as
we know it among the realms truly began
the one being and the elder gods existed
as the deities within the universe the
elder gods sought to remove the one
being's limitless power by dividing the
deity among the realms as artifacts
known as kamidogu anyone capable of
uniting the kami dogu pieces with a
sacred amulet would obtain the godlike
power of the one being as the story goes
in battle of the realms it is known that
the mad god shinnok has vigorously
sought the one being's power so he can
merge the realms and wipe them out of
existence the linguae grandmaster and
his cyborg puppets merely act as
mindless mercenaries doing chinook's
bidding upon realizing chinook's true
identity after giving him the final
kamidogu piece it's apparent that the
grandmaster knows he's made a terrible
mistake but he doesn't get to sit with
that reality long as china calls upon
the forces of the nether realm to
destroy the grand master and his cyborgs
by the time kuai liang and scorpion
arrive it's too late shinaka started
merging with the power of the one being
after a long and arduous tournament with
plenty of death to go around the
tournament delivers one final blow
raiden accepts the challenge to face
shao khan immortal combat the barbaric
dictator beats the former thunder guard
and kills him most to liu kang's horror
but before liu kang's friend the mentor
meets his end he is sure to tell lou
that even though his parents died when
he was very young they died protecting
and loving him this is the fire lukang
needs heading into his fight with the
outworld leader after finding some inner
strength and harnessing his chi liu kang
is able to dispel shang tsung's curse on
his arm and defeat shao khan he then
frees katana from her imprisonment and
the group begins to celebrate the
victory but unfortunately they're unable
to get too far along in the celebration
before the elder gods appear and alert
liu kang to the impending challenge
ahead
chinook takes on the power of the one
being and grows to a massive size with
the absorption of the deity's power
comes the merging of the realms all the
realms begin blending together which
means humans and earth realm are now at
the mercy of the ravenous denizens of
outworld while the realms are consumed
in chaos the elder gods lend their power
to liu kang so he can attempt to defeat
a seemingly invincible being with his
newfound power liu king takes the form
of a massive dragon not unlike the one
you see in the famous mortal kombat logo
through the history of the video game
series liu kang has been known to
perform fatalities and animalities where
he can morph into a dragon and chomp on
his opposition so we're in familiar
territory with this one while shinnok
and liu kang engage in a giant battle at
the center of the merging realms the
rest of earth's champions scattered to
assist helpless civilians from the chaos
of the moment lou kang almost meets his
match but the deadly duo consisting of
the newly adorned sub-zero and scorpion
intervene before the giant shinnok won
being monstrosity can deliver a killing
blow to dragon lou kang the dragon then
manages to retaliate and finish off the
giant deity for good then using his
divine power liu kang separates the
realms and puts things back in order
nothing has been confirmed regarding
immortal combat battle of the realm
sequel but it's a strong possibility
after all why create a new mk series
brand called mortal kombat legends and
stop at only two titles also a few
threads are left open for potential
future story lines shao khan has been
defeated but he wasn't killed in fact
jax poses a question in the film's final
moments on a happier note the elder gods
likely restored raiden to both life and
his full thunder god glory as the camera
pans out of the arena into the end
credits we can see the familiar
lightning strike that often heralds
raiden's arrival we simply have to see
lou kang and lord raiden's reunion
raiden's death was tragic for the young
warrior and it'd be nice to see the two
tackle a new world threatening issue
together mortal kombat law is filled to
the brim with heroes and villains so
there's no shortage of possibilities for
the future of this animated series
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you